santé ou la sécurité c'est ce que vient
trancher le projet de loi c 22 qui a été
présentée aujourd'hui il décriminaliser
pas la possession simple de drogue
comme plusieurs le réclame m et propose
une réforme qui comprend l'abolition
pour certains crimes de peines
d'emprisonnement minimale obligatoire et
ça arrive au mans aussi faut-il rappeler
qu'il ya un autre projet de loi qui
revient la chambre des communes le
projet de loi c 7 qui a été amendé par
le sénat sur l'aide médicale à mourir
puis aussi cette controverse entourant
les armes à feu mon invité le ministre
de la justice et procureur général du
canada monsieur david lam ici merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
monsieur la médecine beaucoup de pain
sur la planche à billets à la chambre
des communes de même pour nous ce soir
lors de cet entretien vous avez choisi
de ne pas décriminaliser la possession
mais d'aborder quand même la question
des drogues la possession de drogue
comme une question de santé publique
qu'est ce que ça change alors ça nous
aide à réduire la sous-représentation
des peuples noirs et et des peuples
autochtones dans le système judiciaire
et dans le système car c'est très
important
c'est vraiment très injuste ce qui se
passe on a honte mais les peuples
autochtones font 5 % la population
canadienne mais il figure pour 30% de la
population incarcérée les peuples noirs
à peu près toi la population mais 7,3 la
population incarcérée
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on doive se
doit corriger façon de cette collection
comporte évidemment de traiter les
problèmes de drogue comme un adolescent
des peines minimales en employant
d'autres tactiques pour des policiers et
des procureurs justement de ne pas faire
engrais ni les personnes dans le système
judiciaire mais de chercher des
solutions basées sous la santé une autre
partie cela volition de certaines paires
minimales obligatoires
ce que les conservateurs ont fait
c'était un échec total
et ça c'est quelque chose qui ne nous
protège pas c'est quelque chose qui fait
en sorte que hong kong et spitz
aux ressources trop d'argent sur nenê
l'énigme non violent souvent des
personnes qui commettent leur came
infractions réactions dans le domaine de
la santé serait plus efficace et il faut
pas oublier non plus qu'on aussi
voudrait remettre redonner la
possibilité au juge de de donner des
ordonnances avec sursis quelque chose
qui ont été effectivement aboli par les
concentrateurs un autre échec total
parce que c'est pour les personnes qui
auront peine de moins de deux ans et qui
ne sont pas une menace pour la société
on pourrait trouver d'autres illusion il
pourrait rester chez eux il pourrait
garder leur emploi ils pourraient garder
leurs enfants restés dans leurs
communautés justement avec avec des
pains constructive et donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on vrai on voudrait redonner au
pouvoir comme on voudrait redonner au
juge donc avec des mesures alternatives
policier même question d'un tribunal
spécialisé ce que je ne me trompe
pour les textes commune oui oui ça
existe déjà ça existe déjà on commence
avec certaines provinces comme le québec
mais ça c'est vraiment la dernière
réponse parce que ça aussi c'est une un
tribunal on veut on veut diriger les
personnes ont d'ores et déjà l'extérieur
en dehors donc même avant même même
avant l'arrestation ou le procès pénal
soit eur soit une policiers alors ça
prend des reçus aux positions de base
exactement la base de départ sera établi
comme une réponse dans le domaine de la
santé
eh bien monsieur lâm et il vous
permettra de vous parler quand même de
l'aide médicale à mourir c'était
projets de loi importants il revient du
sénat le projet de loi c 'est il devrait
être adopté au plus tard le 26 février
pour se conformer aux ordonnances de la
cour
avez vous confiance qu'il va être
adoptées telles que dans le fond vous le
vouliez au départ c'est à dire vous
conformer au jugement touchant delà du
pour les maladies physiques d'une
extrême souffrance
après avoir éliminé le critère de mort
raisonnablement prévisibles oui il faut
absolument être en harmonie avec
l'addition d'un touch ont évidemment le
sénat fait son travail
ils nous ont donné 5 ils ont ils ont
fait un travail acharné et avec beaucoup
d'empathie
donc c'est un nom qui le tour maintenant
de regarder ce que c'est de pouvoir
si si on voudrait accepté les
amendements si on ne me les modifier
donc c'est vraiment une analyse qu'on
est en train de faire il doit il faut le
faire je tuais moi je peux vous assuré
mamadou sow que je vais remuer ciel et
terre pour que on arrive à la bonne
conclusion avant la date limite de la
cour supérieure ce qui vendredi prochain
au fond parce que pour être très clair
pour que les gens puissent nous suivre
monsieur l'amitié c'est que d'éliminer
les critères de mort raisonnablement
prévisibles pour les personnes atteintes
par exemple comme madame jade eu de
problème très grave physique les maladie
de lou gehrig des maladies dégénératives
sur le plan physique
c'était ça l'objectif c'était soit
respecté l'ordonnancé de la cour
mais là on revient du sénat avec
notamment la volonté de permettre
l'adoption de déclaration anticipée pour
les maladies dégénératives et cognitives
comme l'alzheimer et à ne pas confondre
avec la maladie mentale qui est un autre
volet dans ces deux colle à ses 14 la
loi dia cinq heures vous obliger à
revoir le show mais comment est ce
possible pour vous de regarder ce que le
sénat vous renvoie en vous penchant sur
ces deux dimensions la et respecter le
délai de 26 c'est quelque chose qu'on
doit évidemment décidé
dans les prochains heures dans les
prochains jours c'est une question très
difficile c'est la raison pour laquelle
on avait dit à 2016 de remettre la
question à une étude approfondie et
c'était la position qu'on avait puis
dans le projet de loi c dans le projet
original donc c'est de vraiment
entreprend cette analyse comme il
fallait et c'est ce qu'on a entendu
atteint oui il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'appuis à travers le canada
je connais bien la situation des malades
de montmagny on a beaucoup d'un parti
pour elle et je lui ai promis de le
faire à la prochaine étape
il y à peu près mais maintenant le sénat
nous a renvoyé le ballon il faut avoir
une question là dessus et vous voulez
faire entendre madame de montigny l état
en entrevue que mon collègue patrice
poids total à elle nous parle des
balises elle qu'elle soit 13 de son
choix personnel mais il n'y a pas encore
de balises connu pour ses maladies
cognitives dégénérative qui permettrait
d'y voir plus clair en l'écoutent
les barèmes serait proche propres à
chacune des personnes donc en fonction
de la valeur de leur choix puis moi ce
que j'ai décidée c'est que ce serait à
partir du moment où je suis plus
autonomes a star ni soins de voir ce que
ma personne c'est à dire manger
maintenant ma faute ma cuillère aller
aux toilettes tout seul quand ça ça
quand ça parle pour moi c'est ce trou
alors ce sont ces critères à elle ses
balises as après différents pour une
autre personne atteinte d'alzheimer
manade de montigny souffre d'alzheimer
précoce elles voudraient avoir la
musicale à mourir quand vous lui disiez
que vous répondriez son appel à la
prochaine étape
la prochaine étape parce que c'est
vendredi prochain monsieur l'amitié où
c'est avec parce que vous êtes un
gouvernement minoritaire les
conservateurs je pense qu'il ferait qu
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
faire quand j'ai donné la réponse
c'était été envisagé dans la prochaine
étape
parce qu'il faut aussi de la polynésie
c'était la revue parlementaire mais n'a
évidemment le seul à nous en avoir le
ballon il faut condition d'appuyer le
sénat sur la question ce que je peux
vous dire j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
d'empathie pour les personnes dans une
telle situation et je comprends le jeu
comprend leur désir de vraiment décidés
cours il voudrait mais aussi des
médecins il ya d'autres personnes autour
qui doivent aussi participer dans le
processus et donc il faut aussi regarder
si on doit les protéger en droit peyrade
c'est une question c'est pour ça que je
vais me permettre d'assister peut-être
une dernière fois à savoir la prochaine
étape moi j'ai pas compris ce que vous
voulez dire pour la prochaine étape
parce que la prochaine étape qu'urgente
pour les personnes qui souffrent de
maladies physiques graves comme madame
delà du la prochaine étape c'est
vendredi pour ses sets c'est seul projet
de départ la prochaine étape qui était
prévu par la loi ces 14 10 à 5 ans la
prochaine étape c'est une réforme
parlementaire
alors pour parler madame de montigné ce
soir pour elle l'a c'est quoi la
prochaine étape pourrait situer vendredi
ou cédant 12 mois ou 18 mois
je n'ai pas une réponse parce que c'est
la question qu'on doit prendre
actuellement encore en tant que parent
c'est exactement la réflexion qu'on
attend trop bas